Republicans demanding some answers after
classified documents were found at
President Biden's former officers days
before the midterms the materials are
from his time as vice president and a
new report says they include
intelligence assessments about Ukraine
Iran and the UK the White House claims
the documents were immediately handed
over to the National Archives and
Biden's attorneys are cooperating with
the doj the president however does not
seem to eager to talk about any of it
[Music]
lawmakers claim there is a double
standard at play after the FBI raid on
Mar-A-Lago
President Biden said during the campaign
that he would be the most he would have
the most transparent Administration in
America yet we find out this happened
November the 2nd days before the midterm
elections and and no one found out about
it I'm not going to be quick to judge I
just know that he said it was very
irresponsible for president Trump to
take classified document to his personal
residence and have him in an unsecured
location and it appears he did the same
thing and some of the media are quick to
dismiss the story
the brief Euphoria on the right that
this would somehow you know exonerate
Trump by what about ISM it's already
turning into a bit of a hangover because
of the stark contrast between the
actions of the current president and the
former guy when it comes to classified
material we all know that Trump is a
liar and a thief we don't think that
Biden is a liar and a thief so we give
him the benefit of the doubts you're
already hearing them equate it to what
happened with former president Trump
even though it is uh very in apples to
oranges situation
Jesse you broke this news to me in a
commercial break yesterday and I looked
at it and thought I had two thoughts
first I thought it was a joke like oh is
this like from the onion or Babylon B
the second thing I thought was if you're
in the Communications office and they
have to call you and tell you this you
immediately just want to throw up your
hands like I I don't know what I can do
for you here
how dare Rachel Maddow sneer at
exoneration through what about ism
that is the Cornerstone of what I do
here and I will be doing it very
effectively I just want to take this
slowly so intelligence reports dealing
with Ukraine Britain and Iran and this
were these were taken out right when he
was leaving the vice presidency so
Ukraine you know what he's trying to
hide from the incoming Trump
Administration obviously uh the British
intelligence document's interesting
because this was the whole Christopher
Steele deal with the Russia collusion in
Iran what was Donald Trump going to do
with Iran he was going to Nuke the nuke
deal so he didn't want the Trump
Administration to have his dirty little
hands on any of those things so he
disappears with the documents
and the Biden Center for diplomacy they
call it a think tank which is
uh generous generous uh they don't open
for an oxymorons they don't open for a
year so where are the documents that are
classified for an entire year and then
who moves those documents into this
Think Tank if you can call it that now
also at the last week of the Biden vice
presidency where was Biden Biden was in
Ukraine
Biden went all the way over to Ukraine
for some reason and that prosecutor was
fired and barisma gives
a load of money to the Atlanta Council
everything just kind of wraps up in a
nice bow so then they opened the Biden
center with Chinese money
he announces he's doing the Biden Center
at UPenn and all of a sudden China
quadruples their donations to the
University of Pennsylvania a lot of it
Anonymous uh so they open up this big
Center 65 75 million dollars donations
flooding in and
the the Biden Center and UPenn
specifically of all the institutions in
the ivy league is the most pro-china
it has the biggest relationship with the
Chinese and their Mantra is basically
like we can't decouple from China China
is great and the Biden Center is at the
Forefront of this big effort now in
terms of the National Security
implications here where do you think the
Chinese have greater access
to a think tank
15-minute bike ride from the Chinese
Embassy in Washington DC or a basement
at Mar-A-Lago on an island in Florida
guarded by the Secret Service I wonder
if the janitors at the Biden Center were
Chinese operatives I can only guess but
I feel like that's just a little bit
more suspicious and there's also these
other emails coming out from the hunter
laptop they were looking at the Biden
Center as basically the Clinton Global
initiative yes and I think Biden was
going to Biden Hunter button was gonna
have an office there now why does Hunter
Biden need an office at the Biden Center
when he already has this other office
that he's sharing with the Chinese in
Georgetown a lot of centers and you can
never get anything out of these centers
you know they have decl they've
classified information at this one and
then they have all the documents about
the rape accusation from that woman when
he was a senator they have those locked
under under guarded key at the
University of Delaware it's like every
every institution that binds associated
with has some sort of national security
or criminal uh implications so I'm just
you know I'm keeping an open mind as
Harold yes and Harold what about that
what about ism
it's good to be back around yeah it's
great to have you I'd say a couple
things I think Jesse's raised a lot of
interesting points and I think a lot of
questions have to be answered I'm not
I'm not certain that Penn is the most
extensive times I think Harvard may
actually have more students from from
China but I think I know where where
you're going and you're it does not at
all mitigate answers that I think have
to be answered questions that need to be
asked some questions and questions that
deserve answers I'd say four other
things very quickly what I'm most
interested in uh in all of this is how
how did it happen I think we need to
trace the chain of custody here and I
hope that from a legal standpoint judge
that certainly has something that has to
be done right away too did President
Biden when he was then citizen uh Biden
when he was before he was president did
he ever review those documents I think
that question if he did he would have
known that they were there and that and
that they should have been returned and
if he did know if he did review them uh
did he know that they were classified
and someone telling me should be
returned I think if he reviewed them he
should have certainly known because they
were they were listed that way uh three
how secure were the documents because
some of the concerns that people had
about the documents being at Mar-A-Lago
was that at least from what we've heard
from the archivists in federal law
enforcement agencies the federal law
enforcement agency the FBI is that they
didn't think that those things were
secure enough and finally had they
checked extensively and exhaustively to
ensure that there are no other documents
there I know one one distinguishing
Factor here is that President Biden's
team apparently self-reported and if
they self-reported on this I've read
some reports where they looked in other
boxes and I'm hopeful that they did look
in other boxes that they have
exhaustively done this done this search
here but politically Danny you're right
this is uh you would you would hate to
get that call yes sir but these things
happen and I I look forward to hearing
the president's answer answers to these
questions and perhaps I think that's one
there's going to be a press conference
in a little bit judge what about the
action the Attorney General took he said
okay well now somebody has gonna have to
look into this as well yeah
you know I I don't I don't trust the
Attorney General enough to say that he's
probably going to recommend a special
prosecutor he's not going to do that I
think that the points at Harold rays are
excellent number one the attorneys
stumbled upon these top secret uh stuff
that you could only read in a skiff that
are marked classified okay number two
they have been there for six years in a
facility that is not locked that is not
secured we have no idea how many people
had access to or actually looked at
these documents that were marked and
there was it was not only not secure but
it was an academic institution anyone
could have had access to that office and
my question is why now were they moving
the office I understand they were moving
the office and then they said they
turned it over immediately immediately
after what after who saw it who saw it
first what is immediate and how how many
people saw it I want to know under oath
how many people saw it what other
classified information is there I'm not
going to rely on their them saying it
was only this amount and this small
amount is not the issue the issue is
very clear you do not have the right to
take that classified information and put
it in a non-classified facility okay
that is the violation whether it's one
or 160 right now they're admitting to 10
or 12 or whatever the number is so it's
it's not allowed period so don't tell me
the media like the media there's nothing
to see here folks nothing to see here at
least Mar-A-Lago was protected by the
Secret Service this is Penn this is an
academic institution and the truth is
Ukraine you know as I recall president
Trump was impeached over a phone call to
the Ukraine trying to find out what Joe
Biden did when he threatened the
prosecutor to get off the case of a
company that his son was working for and
by the way as vice president he didn't
have power to declassify so he's got
none of those defenses and you know the
man who couldn't call who couldn't wait
to call Trump irresponsible now can't
answer the question he can't answer any
question and finally the what about ISM
I'd like to do a what about ISM with
Hillary Clinton she still is the worst
33 000 emails they were all classified
when everybody asked him where they were
she simply destroyed them yep also why
isn't the media mad about the timing
because apparently this was known before
the midterm elections I know that was
weird and that what a surprise that it
came out now all these delays seem to
only go in One Direction where the
shocking photographs that are set up
like court evidence but I said this a
couple of days ago payback is a Hillary
Clinton and
I want to know when the raids starts I
want to see what's in their underwear
drawer and if it's disposable uh I know
that the media's response is that you
know with Trump it's treason with uh or
worse than Watergate and with Joe Biden
it's a nothing suppository we see that
coming as well we knew this would happen
we're not stupid but we're different
right they may be right this might be a
nothing burger and we and we felt that
trumps was a nothing Burger but we never
change our story based on the team that
we support we know that this is probably
in my in my view I would sug I would
always think that the person who ever
packed that stuff in there probably just
packs stuff in there do you ever have a
mover they come to your house and then
you're unpacking and they packed
singularly a disposable spoon from from
takeout and it's all packed in newspaper
what are you doing so who knows it could
be some idiot who did that but but the
thing is I would not be doing my job if
I didn't raise the the important
questions that need to be that need to
be raised about what actually happened
do we know that there aren't nuclear
secrets in there perhaps he exchanged
nuclear secrets to China for the 10
percent huh that's where that's a
question we're worth raising what if he
has Barack Obama's real birth
certificate oh no and that's what got
him the VP job blackmail the black he's
been blackmailing the black males
but if this is true and by the way just
raising some questions documents vital
to National Security he needs to be frog
marched Joe Biden into prison
immediately no bail for him and if it
turns out he's a traitor I'm just going
to go by with all those Talking Heads on
CNN and MSNBC said and prescribed about
Trump I'm not going to go for anything
more than what they suggested hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now